you know without further Ado maybe what
I want to do here is just demonstrate
whether it is difficult or not to escape
from prison as Robin reported we have
big news that the dude in Pennsylvania
who escaped that prison thank God it was
making law enforcement look bad uh the
report is they now caught this dude and
they had horses dogs drones helicopters
men on the ground a horse you know it
was just like they tried everything to
find this guy they had to do it well
they got them they got them and that's
the important thing and uh now let me go
over to our Studios where we have this
wall situation set up and as you can see
there's JD
Gary Mike Traynor and mehmed and can I
point something out by the way unless
you think I'm paranoid like I come in
here and everyone has a helmet and gear
and they say oh we don't have one for
Yuma Matt like sorry we didn't get a
helmet
you're using this one it's just a
strange coincidence oh now I have to
share one okay yes please
Howard the reason we're in this order is
because Mehmet chose the order clearly
for what reason why did you pick this
well let's be frank these three
shouldn't even be attempting this I mean
these are three older fat guys like I'm
worried Mike's gonna make the building
collapse before we even get a chance say
get a chance to do this I'm the only one
who can reasonably reasonably be
expected to pull this off first of all
to be fair JD always wears a helmet he
always outfit in with one every day and
uh and you will get a helmet as well so
don't think you're being singled out JD
the let's set you up first you've got
your helmet on and you got your knee
pads on and let's see can you pull off
what this prisoner in Pennsylvania did
go ahead I'll go now mind you the
prisoner didn't have any of this extra
equipment here's Jayden
[Music]
all right I'll do the play-by-play
JD has his feet his his hands are
against the wall his feet just fell down
all right building just shook you would
think there was an earthquake all right
so uh JD attempted it he got as far as
putting one foot up on the wall here
goes Gary Gary is now going to attempt
it his hands are against the wall and
now he's attempt Gary
all right here goes Gary
's trying it's gonna hurt him
that's about as good as I can do he got
a little further than JD but you know
Gary has a metal titanium knees you're
saying his knees are because they're
titanium better iPhone knees no I'm
saying they're worse they are they are
worse all right here goes um that's hard
man I'm telling you red you were red
yeah all right here comes Mike trainer
who quite frankly I do agree with mehmed
who looks very out of shape
all right
here we go one two three
oh he can't even get JD got further than
him want to count some more
that was up that counts what I mean what
constitutes doing it doing it
hang on I got up
all right here we go
[Music]
so far Mike trainer got far I see Mike
working on his wrists all right I want
to point out like there's there's like
potato chips
attraction shut up whiny [__] here goes
my met that's how the prisoner did it
one leg up
okay all right here we go yeah you're
ready for all your apologies here we go
okay oh
okay I have not ever attempted this he
slipped off the wall
s see the Wall's too it's too close
together this isn't what the guy did
didn't complain
don't you think it's interesting that
you were boasting that you'd be the only
one to come close to be able to do it
I'm honestly stunned I don't know what
else to say other than I think you know
we're not can I try different shoes go
ahead and try different shirts okay wear
JD's shoes see if you can do it with
goodies yeah I just find this very
interesting and as we know the prisoner
did not have a choice of shoes but I
want to give them that every choice the
length of the wall any of it that's
right but now do you feel better
the shoes are not mine or someone else's
shoes they're a little bit big stop
whining okay just [__] climb gosh no
one was talking during yours
here we go my Med is trying again
[Music]
it looks like a ballerina
he's trying to [__] the mattress
there he goes all right there you go
okay
[Laughter]
you did a couple of steps you did a
couple of steps you got a couple not so
easy
I'm out of the prison once you went to
your churches I knew it was the shoes
that's all it took it's all I think
thank you that was not graceful all
right again you all doubted me and I
proved to be
correcting up to the barbed wire oh JD
you didn't even get vertical shut up I
give her to go for a second or whatever
Horizon
there's 11 tries two pairs of shoes and
I won so
foreign